الاحتجاجات في ايران مستمره منذ قضت
الشابه مهسا اميني في احد مراكز الاعتقال
التابعه لشرطه الاخلاق فسادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي يبدو ان النظام يواجه
اسرارا غير مسبوق وتحديا واضحا للتغيير
فكسرت محرمات وركائز للنظام مفعما بغضب
واستياء شعبيين يتابع الشعب الايراني في
ثورته اسهم الوضع الاقتصادي والمتدهور
والتراجع العمله اضافه الى القيود
الاجتماعيه التي يعاني منها السكان البالغ
عددهم 85 مليون منذ عقود في تصاعد وسيره
الاحتجاجات واتساعها التظاهرات ليست جديده
على ايران لكنها الحركه الحاليه غير
مسبوقه لجهه مدتها واتساع نطاقها الجغرافي
والطبقات الاجتماعيه والمجموعات الاثنيه
والمطالبه العلنيه بوضع حد للنظام
احرقت صور المرشد علي خامنائي وصور
الخميني وسارت نساء في الشوارع من دون
تغطيه رؤوسهم واطلقت حملات تضامن دوليه
كثيره لدعم النساء بوجه اله قمع النظام
اله القمع عزازتها السلطات باحدى باحكام
اعدام ضد المتظاهرين نفذت منها حكمين هذا
الشهر بينما يواجه اكثر من 80 شخصا اخرين
اتهامات
يعني تعرضهم الاحتمال صدور احكام اعدام
ضدهم اضيفه الى ذلك ما ذكرتهم منظمه حقوق
الانسان في ايران التي تتخذ من اوسلو مقر
لها ان
476 شخصا على الاقل بينهم 64 تقل اعمارهم
عن 18 عاما قتلوا في جميع انحاء البلاد
بايدي قوى الامن خلال قمع تظاهرات
[موسيقى]